foreign
[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Tuesday November 29th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal
last year Facebook parent meta began
releasing quarterly reports on widely
viewed content basically summaries of
the top 20 posts that were viewed most
on its platform the goal was to show the
range of content going viral on Facebook
what it ended up showing was that
virtually all of the top ranked content
was spammy over sexualized or generally
with the company classified as
regrettable
Not only was it an embarrassment for the
company Executives according to sources
and documents reviewed by The Wall
Street Journal it also threatened to
throw off Facebook's plans to change
users news feeds
the company got to work and the latest
report released last week shows only one
of the top 20 posts qualified as
engagement bait
so how did Facebook deal with the
problem and what can other social media
platforms learn from its efforts
joining us to discuss this is our
technology reporter Jeff Horowitz so
Jeff what kind of content are we talking
about when Facebook said it had too much
quote regrettable content on people's
feeds so this is a definitional issue in
the regrettable as it was originally
conceived by the company was like
engagement bait things that violated the
rules it was I think a fairly
restrictive definition stuff they didn't
want at the top of the platform so they
were moving to adopt reels which is a
short form video product and instead of
seeing things that were reshared by
people you knew from pages so much they
were going to be directly recommending
entertaining videos it's very much like
tick tock and some of the things I think
that they had initially assumed which is
that the kind of low quality content
things that have bad lighting or like
unclear what's going on people's filming
a video on a TV screen you know things
that just look terrible as well as our
quote unquote gross or a waste of time
those things weren't captured by their
initial definition of regrettable and so
they had to expand it how did all this
content come to you know be at the top
of users feed on Facebook so all of it
really thrived in the ecosystem Facebook
setup right which is that the
distribution of content is governed by
how people engage with it you know if
nobody is liking sharing it commenting
on it it's not going to go anywhere on
the platform and what the company has I
think been coming to conclude in the
last few years and and certainly is
present in this work is that maybe just
because you get a rise out of people and
get a response doesn't mean they
actually want the content in question
and so there was a concern that in
particular with reels that the content
quality was going to be really a problem
one of the things I think that was a big
Focus was quote unquote aggression and
that was videos of people fighting
whether like physically in a Walmart or
screaming at each other on the street or
what have you videos of people being
angry and nasty to each other really did
well and they had to figure out how to
address that and make sure that that
wasn't going to be a lot of what was in
there and Facebook really had to think
about that because it's focused on
making this pivot to Reels its short
form video where it's competing against
Tick Tock right
exactly for a number of years the
company's position on content quality
was look like we don't get to choose
what people like you know whatever Rises
to the top is represents the People's
Choice was kind of the attitude about
this internally and it turns out that
that may have been a little bit
misplaced and particularly when it came
to something that was more like Tick
Tock which is reals I don't think the
company was looking forward to being
responsible for those recommendations if
that makes sense like this wasn't stuff
that someone's friends had liked this
was just sort of Facebook saying hey you
should check out this content and then
it would be a whole bunch of fight
videos
all right so let's talk about Facebook's
reaction to this what is it done to try
and remove this kind of content from
going viral so at the beginning of this
year the company put together a Content
quality war room which was product and
design and integrity which is kind of
the user safety division all working
together to try to Define what makes for
a garbage video and post and to figure
out how to implement that and code that
into Facebook systems so trying to
prevent the worst type of content from
getting to the top basically and how do
we know this
so that all came from internal documents
you know I think the company has sort of
walked a line between wanting to
acknowledge that content quality on
Facebook is a priority and that there
have been in some improvements and also
not wanting to acknowledge how bad the
uh problem was right so Facebook did
release its widely viewed content report
almost all the content on it is just
fine very little engagement bait it's
nothing particularly scandalous or awful
the thing they left out of that at
Public Announcement which they did
acknowledge internally and some of the
documents I've seen was that pretty much
all of it like literally 100 percent of
the content in the top 20 posts from a
year ago was low quality or regrettable
you you know we've been having a lot of
conversations on this show a lot of
people have been talking more widely
about social media content and content
moderation is there anything that other
platforms or even Facebook itself could
learn from this experience
yeah over a number of years Facebook has
had to be think its initial position
that people engage with was what they
wanted that was always the company's
assumption that intervening would be
biased because if something was getting
re-shared broadly that must mean that
people really wanted to see it and
I think time and time again the company
saw examples it was kind of embarrassed
by what was at the top of the chart and
over time I think it started developing
metrics for what users valued and it
turns out that what users reacted to
wasn't the same thing that what users
valued and so I think when we were
looking at say Twitter and Elon Musk
right now the whole idea of I want this
to be a platform for free speech and I
want it to be something that's
newsworthy and reliable and trustworthy
all of those things it doesn't just
happen on its own it seems like what
Facebook's learned is that you have to
go into this stuff with some level of
values not whether it's you know whether
one should or shouldn't be able to say a
particular thing but just like
that you can't use sort of spammy
content and engagement tricks to beat
the algorithm and get to the top you
have to do something to protect yourself
against that all right that's our
reporter Jeff Horowitz Jeff thanks so
much for joining us certainly thank you
for having me and that's it for today's
Tech news briefing if you're looking for
more Tech stories check
site dub dubsj.com
The Wall Street Journal thanks for
listening
[Music]
[Music]